[Musique]
il y a une classe dans la société qui
pense encore plus à l'agent de les
riches ce sont les pauvres
oscar wilde
je vais vous poser quelques questions
qui rencontre tend à nouveau marcher
quand nous nous battons dans les rues
dans les taxis puce désarticulé
aux abords des marchés à la recherche de
contrats ponctuels quelques fois devant
les étalages de lâcher de l'irak
c'est le choix pauvres et ils
représentent la plus grande partie de la
population de choisey cents ménages sur
dix il fit dans une précarité
alimentaire et sanitaire
pratiquement dans une insécurité
matériel qu'ils rencontrent tant dans
les clubs privés de la ville de nouveaux
massifs dans les restaurants huppés la
ville de formation en première classe
des avions c'est
le choix riche il est propriétaire d'une
entreprise investisseurs il jouit de la
vie et surtout il a le temps le temps de
créer le temps de voyager et le temps de
se cultiver et surtout il fait partie
des cinq cent de la population mondiale
qui se partagent 95 % des richesses de
la planète
qu'ils rencontrent tombent dans les
supermarchés de la vie de leur machine
dans les endroits les plus branchés
ville de propager
ou alors stationné devant les meilleures
écoles à midi c'est le choix moyens que
nous allons appeler le sud du choix
monsieur vos choix lui il est employé
dans une entreprise ou alors indépendant
et il dépend sensiblement de son salaire
ou ne s'isolait donné peu de ses
honoraires
comment victime monsieur nos choix
quotidien
voici ses finances personnelles
en fait c'est un exemple les états
financiers sont inspirés livre de
thierry passiez quand il a un salaire de
500 milles l'impôt et pensionnés à la
source comme vous le savez et le reste
est infecté entièrement aux dépenses de
base qui sont tous le savent et
l'alimentation la santé
le loyer l'eau l'électricité
bien évidemment la communication en ce
moment puisqu'on ne peut pas se passer
et l'école des enfants pour la plupart
du temps qu'est ce qui lui reste en fin
de mois
c'est en fait ce n'est même pas 0
la chemise est au juste pour la forme en
fait la nba qui est la marge brute
d'autofinancement de monsieur choix est
généralement négatives et oecd il quand
son salaire augmente les dépenses
augmentent avec les salaires les
dépenses de base d'abord ou même pas
d'abord les dépenses de battre landreau
augmente aussi les dépenses de base
commenté sadad le style de vie suit est
sage ic2 forme de dépenses
supplémentaires qui sont les dépenses de
loisirs
c'est à dire du sperme et voyager de
sortir
grieco paris qualifient soirée
anniversaire et il s'ajoute encore des
dépenses de conforme parce qu'un
monsieur joshua exprime le souhait de
posséder sa propre maison
son propre vécu et passion pour ça il
faut et du pays cette maison or sa mpm
est négatif donc il ne peut s'en
dépêtrer de 50 cette situation là ne
l'emploie et il est dominé par ses
besoins matériels
identifiant ensemble les potentiels de
ce choix de pouvoir améliorer un tant
soit peu son sort de pouvoir avoir le
choix de pouvoir prétendre aussi fait
partie qui devrait pas faire partie des
5 % de la population qui se partagent 95
% des richesses de la planète qui est en
prépa mais peu douati fait avant d'y
parvenir quelques concepts clés nous
allons parler d'actifs
nous allons parler le passif nous allons
parler de revenus passifs et nous allons
parler d'actifs a vu le passif
bien avant cela je vais pouvoir définir
la chaise casque et la richesse
en fait la richesse et le temps la
richesse est possédé du temps avoir du
temps pour soi
bien évidemment après avoir comblé tous
ses besoins
parce que le temps vous permet de vous
consacrer à vous à vos proches de vous
consacrer à votre passion comme on la
noue vient parler de tirs et de fait et
de bénéficier de son temps
finalement alors nous allons oublier un
peu la comptabilité
ici nous parlons de finances quand on
parle d' actifs il s'agit de tout ce que
monsieur vous choix pour scène et y fait
rentrer de l'argent dans ses poches
monsieur mouchoirs à acheter un véhicule
qu'il a peints en jaune qui fait la
ligne roi chez poste se met lui la
reprise en haïti pour monsieur noah
le papier le passif pour monsieur vous
choix c'est aussi possèdent et qui fait
sortir l'argent de ce qu'ils pensent de
la même manière si je dois m'arrêter au
niveau de l'exemple du véhicule le vécu
de monsieur vos choix l'utilisent pour
se rendre à son service pour accompagner
les enfants à l'école
ce véhicule est homme massif au monsieur
le choix il ne s'agit pas d'un actif
parce que dès le moment où vous achetez
ce véhicule vous le commandez de l'ifaw
vous n'avez plus le revendre à ce même
prix et si vous ne vendez pas fou le
garder et le peuple et de l'argent vous
allez devoir acheter légalement
l'entretenir régulièrement pour le
garder en état recrue ben ali or le
passif ses revenus qu'on acquiert à ne
rien faire c'est un revenu qui n'exige
pas votre présence pour ceux générés
contrairement au mot revenus actifs pied
par exemple salaire le salaire oblige
vous soyez présents sur le lieu du
travail quand vous n'êtes pas là eh ben
on ne nous paye pas pour cette journée
là quand vous ne donnez pas de vent très
fort comme joubert pas ça quand vous
avez le salaire c'est un actif vous
devez activer pour avoir
tandis qu'un revenus passifs je voulais
vous donner l'exemple taxi et ben le
versement en fin de journée qu'on vient
d'accès à monsieur choix et un menu
passif
enfin a dit favre ne pas siffler c'est
tout ce que je viens de dire
c'est tout simplement quelque chose de
ce choix pour scène et qui lui
rapportera de l'argent
il a un téléphone qui conscients voisins
au poil la rue pour vendre les unités ce
téléphone est un actif avec le massif il
a un complexe commercial qui l'a
construit et qui lui rapporte du loyer
en fin de mois ce pamphlet et donne
actifs à bord une passif
quelles sont les clés pratiques que nous
proposons à nos yeux le choix pour un
tant soit peu amélioré son sort
le premier les éléments qui a évidemment
nous heureusement encore c'est un peu
comme si nous étions entendus changer sa
façon de penser didier beny samedi que
les deux forces infaillible du
changement c'est la pensée et l'action
il faut forcément commencer par le monde
à commencer par changer par exemple les
habitudes que nous avons de penser qu'
il faut faire de grandes études pour
devenir riche
le nom tout le monde a la capacité peut
on peut devenir riche à tout âge à ce
propos qu' aux âneries vie parle de
priorité de riches et de priorités des
pauvres qui sont tout à fait contraire
napoléon il insiste sur le fait qu'il
faut le désirez il faut le vouloir
il ne faut pas seulement dire je me
changeais il faut aussi vouloir changer
pour y arriver
enfin je dirais des années qu'on lui dit
que chacun de nous ennuie possède un
plan financie mental quel est votre plan
financier mental pensez vous que
l'argent peut vous aider à avancer
pensez vous que l'argent et comme on dit
l'afrique
de tous les maux mais on dit aussi que
le manque d'argent n'est pas bon non
plus
la deuxième l'est c'est de multiplier
les sources de revenus passifs
nul n'ignore la plage le bénéfice de la
diversification ne vous concentrer pas
sur g1taxi qui fait exact au poste
je m'arrête là le jour il ya un problème
avec le transport vous n'avez pas votre
rôle passif c'est pourquoi il est
préférable de multiplier autant que
possible les sources de revenus passifs
dans le but 2 dans le but d'atteindre le
montant de vos dépenses de base
la troisième heure propositions et
celles de diminuer les dépenses
les dépenses auxquelles nous nous
attaquons principalement ce sont bien
évidemment les dépens de roy
sion et les dépenses de confort ici je
dirais que les seules baisses qui sont
bénéfiques
ce sont celles que l'on long l'obtient
pour acquérir un actif qui vous produit
du revenu le premier par une dette pour
consommer enfin épargné
dès le moment où on veut diminuer les
banques
en réalité ça permet de dégager une
marge brute d'autofinancement positive
que vous pouvez épargner
je m'invente bien évidemment mais dans
l'intention de l'investir de l'investir
ac loire à l'acquisition de nouveaux
actifs
après le passif pasteur ce sont ces
actifs à bord du passif qui vous
permettent de nous donner de la liberté
par exemple thierry parce qu'il dit que
chaque dollar que je dépense décide
si je reste esclaves ou si je me libère
choisissons de nous éduquer en finance
voici dans les états financiers ipo
je dis bien ibeo s'est pacsée
nous sommes dans un monde qui n'est pas
parfait mais voici ce que deviendraient
les états financiers de monsieur
mouchoirs si il prend en compte toutes
les recommandations conduit à faire
notamment changer sa façon de penser
avec son salaire devenu en offrant
l'impôt est ponctionné les dépenses de
passe continue aussi parce que
quelquefois croyez-moi nous exagérons
aussi sous les dépenses de pacs les
dépenses de base en diminuer les
dépenses de confort sont sensiblement
diminué une fille mais il ya la présence
maintenant donné de revenus passifs
du côté des mauves ne tue côté des
entrées et avec l'ennemi passif qu'il
génère il peut valablement couvrir ses
dépenses de base à ce moment là
croyez-moi mesure choix à nos choix
et heureusement il a le choix pourquoi
parce qu'il dégage aujourd'hui une marge
brute d'autofinancement positive
les 1700 et ben il est libre de se dire
enfin avec ce que je dégage je peux
m'acheter un véhicule parce que les
priorités des niches sont de devenir
d'abord riche le confort après et enfin
la sécurité alors que les priorités des
pauvres c'est d'abord la sénilité le
confort et puis après pensé à devenir
riche
voilà je vous connaissent
[Applaudissements]